[Music]
important to the ecosystem which is one
of the reasons why we're moving them all
this distance and doing all this effort
to get them there we're hoping that
translocations like this going forward
will maybe save or certainly make a
difference in the numbers of rhinos in
in the world by moving them to to
different recipient locations in
different countries
[Music]
we hope that 10 years from now there
will be a thriving population of white
runners and sanov obviously for the
benefit of the of the park itself and
the ecosystem there but also for the
benefit of the people of mozambique
[Music]
we've done certain predators that we've
moved in and a lot of elephants we've
moved in now and now it's the turn for
rhino
it's very exciting now to to complete
the the presence of historical species
[Music]